hello I'm Hannah K and welcome to this
intelligence Square debate with Susan
Blackmore and Kevin Mitchell on the
right hand side of your screen you'll
see a link where you can get a copy of
Kevin's new book free agents how
Evolution gave us free will but now I'm
delighted to hand over to our chair njel
wetton he's a philosopher and co-host of
the podcast philosopher bites over to
you Nigel Hello I'm Nigel won and
welcome to this intelligence Square
debate Free Will is an illusion with
Kevin Mitchell and Susan
Blackmore the topic of Free Will has
vexed philosophers for Millennia the
basic problem is this as I see it anyway
and I'm I'm willing to be corrected on
this look I'm having a valtion now I'm
having a a thought I'm going to move my
right hand and lo and behold there it
goes it
moves how that happens to me is still a
little bit of a mystery particularly as
it feels that I'm in control but at the
same time because I'm somebody who
doesn't believe in spiritual
explanations magical explanations from
outside science I think that everything
that I am can be explained in terms of
webs of cause and effect and if I knew
enough about or if other people knew
enough about my genes about my
environment um the conditioning that
I've had the circumstances immed medely
now they would be able to predict
exactly what I would do because cause
and effect just works that way and there
doesn't seem to be room for this magical
thing coming in Free Will unless you
kind of Imagine something like a soul
inhabiting the body which we're Beyond I
hope so that's how I see the problem of
free will it's something that's been a
problem explaining how Free Will of the
kind of experience Free Will could be
compatible with a scientific world world
viiew and um we're lucky enough to have
two eminent scientists to talk on either
side of this debate and there are more
than two sides I have to say so we're
going to begin
with uh an opening speech from each of
our our guests first Susan Blackmore is
going to speak for the motion Free Will
is an
illusion and Susan is a psychologist
who's well known for her books which
explore consciousness memetics
Evolution and spirituality particularly
her first book beyond the body which was
held as a classic um IT addresses the
unusual topic of of outof body
experiences and was inspired by her own
experience of being outside her body
she's a visiting professor at the
University of Plymouth freelance writer
and she gives lectures all over the
world her latest book is seeing myself
what outof body experiences tell us
about life death and the mind so Susan
could you give us sort of eight or nine
minutes just as a general introduction
telling us why and how Free Will is an
illusion well you've done a good job of
saying what you think Free Will is uh
and I completely agree with you I would
like to say what an illusion is I've had
trouble with this with Consciousness um
uh because people have said oh well you
don't think Consciousness exists no I
say it's an illusion and so I went to
the dictionary and looked it up an
illusion is something that is not what
it seems to be and I think Consciousness
and Free Will are both examples of that
as is the self who would be the one who
had Free Will so I would add to your
description of what we mean by Free Will
something like is this kind of feeling
well you you you mentioned the soul or
the spirit but this feeling that I
inside um am in charge that I'm
controlling this body that I'm making my
brain do the things it does um and I
just want to mention my favorite quote
on this which um which probably you know
already Samuel Johnson you know more
than 200 years ago said all theory is
against the freedom of the will and all
experiences for it so we've had an
awfully long time of people knowing
there can't be there Can't Be Free Will
and yes I'm sure that it's an illusion
it's an illusion that um Neuroscience is
really uncovering now I mean
Neuroscience has just gone Bonkers and
wonderful in in this Century really so
we can look inside the brain and we can
see how the self is made up you know
there isn't this magical being inside
who would be doing controlling the brain
or or whatever there is a model of a
self um a construction inside the brain
you know with the uh um body schema
organized in the temporo parial junction
its connections to the controls in
prefrontal cortex the memories being
brought up from parietal loes and know
the self is a big construction it comes
and goes it's not built up all the time
comes back and you get the illusion of
continuity and you get the illusion of
of being in charge so the problem has
got worse and that means worse because
of the amazing neuroscience and and and
understanding of genetics and so on that
means we're even more obliged to
actually do something about it and say
you know what are we going to do um you
know when you think about things like
moving your arms you know most people
are happy to say
well yeah I didn't do that in my free
will even the words I'm speaking kind of
seem to come out of nowhere but what
about more difficult decisions like um I
don't know whether to take that job or
whether to go to this place or how about
um whether to join in this debate um so
imagine me sitting here at my desk and
um and um Along Comes an email that says
would you like to take part in this in
this debate and I sit there and I think
well would I yes no um I'm tired I got
chronic fatigue I do too much on the
other hand it sounds really
interesting many people would think
that's what requires free will but I
would say that it doesn't it requires
this whole body here with its education
and its past and everything else to
um to make the decision to weigh it up
to go these are the advantages these are
the disadvantages not because they have
free will but because that's what this
person does given her background her
brain her genes her environment and so
on so that's where we are well what do
we do about it I I would like to discuss
this in two ways one is just referring
to me or you the individual person and
the other to do with the effects on
society if we give up the idea of Free
Will and I think we have to give up the
idea of Free Will I've been trying to do
that most of my life since I was a
student um in in the early 1970s in
Oxford I can remember um arguing with my
boyfriend about it and I came to the
conclusion that well there is will you
can have stronger or weaker will but the
will isn't free you can have freedom of
course you can have freedom some people
are Freer than others some people people
are in prison some people are stuck in
refugee camps some people have have no
money and no opportunities or few
opportunities others are free to you
know but it's that's nothing to do with
the will that's to do with their
circumstances so what happens if we give
it
up well people are very resistant to
giving it up um and I can understand why
it's a bit scary um I've had the great
good Fortune to interview lots of um
psychologists uh uh philosophers
neuroscientists um many of these were
for my book conversations on
Consciousness and um I asked all of them
and many other people do you have free
will what I found quite shocking really
was that the majority of these Highly
Educated mostly brilliant thinkers said
well yes you know it's it's not really
what people think it is but we have to
live as if we have free will well I say
that's not so it's hard to give up
feeling as if there is Free Will my own
response now uh after all this time I
hardly get the feeling of Free Will
anymore but it is an intense feeling as
Samuel Johnson mentioned in the
beginning experience is is for it but my
response is oh here comes that feeling
again well it's just a feeling get on
with making the decisions because that's
what what has to be done in in this
circumstance and what's the effect of
that is the effect um that I run a mock
and do terrible things and go around
murdering people or you know at the very
least stamping on frogs or I don't know
why I thought of that why she thought of
that um or being unkind or beastly to
people or but why why would this human
being do that if she's been brought up
the way she has and been taught to be
sensible and polite and so on
and also discover that actually on the
whole when you're nice to people they're
nice back and life's easier and you know
life goes on if you let go of the whole
idea of free
will this comes up in something else I'm
very interested in I'm I'm not a
Buddhist but I've been training in Zen
for um decades and and within that
tradition it's supposed to end up with
non-meditation or non-doing and that
idea is not that this body doesn't do
anything obviously gets on with its life
but it's the idea that there is no
longer the sense of this mythical
construction of self there's no longer
the belief that that this is an entity
that that is the doer of the things that
are done and letting go of that in those
Traditions leads to people being uh more
compassionate more caring because they
see other people in in the same way so
it's not so scary you can do it if you
want to if you really believe that it's
illusion you can do it and what about
the effects on society well this is
something that lots and lots of people
have argued about Sam Harris Dan dennit
various what the the fear is that um
society would collapse because our legal
system would collapse well I think
that's rubbish I I I remember a
wonderful argument I had with the
philosopher Dan dennit now we were
sitting at my kitchen table and I really
really pushed him on this free will
thing because everything that he's
taught about Consciousness that there's
no audience sitting inside the brain
there's no one in charge in there um
there's no Central meanor all these
arguments that he's had should lead him
to say that Free Will is an illusion and
he doesn't why not I'm pretty sure from
that and other conversations it's
because he like so many people are
afraid of the effect on society that our
legal system would break down but it
wouldn't we would just replace it
instead of a kind of retributive you
know punishing you CU you're bad kind of
approach we would have to say if
somebody does a bad thing what is the
best thing to do for them and for the
rest of society if we punish them in
some way put them in prison whatever
will that help them to not do bad things
again will it help uh other people will
it put deter other people from doing
those kind of bad things or in some
extremes should we actually lock this
person up because they really are a
threat to society all that would carry
on and we'd get away from these black
and white lines about are they actually
you know capable of of making the
decisions or so on that would all be
wrapped up in decide what would the
outcome would be knowing that the reason
these people do bad things is from their
background uh bad luck they may have had
the situations they got thrown into um
their lack of Education uh the drugs
that they've taken because they couldn't
cope all of those things we would be I
think more compassionate and better able
to run the society so I don't have those
fears anymore I think we'll be fine in
fact I think we should all accept the
science the
evidence U Johnson's theory about Free
Will and I think we would all be better
off if we accepted that Free Will is an
illusion so thanks very much um Susan uh
now we're going to turn to the other
side of the debate where Kevin Mitchell
is going to argue against the motion
that Free Will is an illusion Kevin
Mitchell is an associate professor of
genetics and Neuroscience at Trinity
College Dublin and he's the author of
innate how the wiring of our brain
shapes who we are he runs a popular blog
called wiring the brain and his work has
appeared in many Publications including
Scientific American the guardian and
psychology today but probably most
relevant is his new book free agents how
Evolution gave us free will so Kevin
could you speak for about 9 minutes on
how Evolution gave us free will and you
why you think Susan is wrong yes thank
you so much for the invitation thanks
very much um to Nigel for the
introduction and to sue for the
introduction to the topic which I think
is um sets the stage really nicely
because it highlights these challenges
that um arise when people think about
Free Will so my own feeling is first of
all that the debates on Free Will are
framed often in ways that are unhelpful
and I think there's three ways in
particular and the first is to take a
really absolutist kind of framing where
you say you have to be making decisions
in a way that's absolutely free from any
prior causes whatsoever in order for
that to qualify as free will so if
anything is impinging on you anything
from your past any goals for your future
any information that you have then
you're not really completely free and it
doesn't count it's just not free will um
and and to me that's just a really
incoherent notion because any any sort
of entity that's making decisions in
that way basically for no reason because
any reason is a cause W would just be
doing things at random it would just be
a random Behavior
generator it wouldn't be a self I mean
the whole point of being a self is to
continue to do things including making
yourself persist through time and so for
me that you know if you want to frame it
in that way it it just doesn't even get
off the ground
um so I would rather ask um you know
more pragmatic kind of questions about
what sort of control we have now another
framing which is what I think Nigel and
Sue both sort of spoke to is this idea
that it has to be somehow just your
conscious self that's in charged some
some kind of thing that that isn't just
your brain working or again it doesn't
count if Neuroscience shows how the
decision- making is happening then you
can say well it's just your brain making
you do things it's not you and I think
again that's a sort of a duelist framing
where there's a there's a physical stuff
but in order for it to count as free
will there has to be some some
immaterial thing some soul or Spirit or
mind that's in charge again I think that
doesn't get off the ground it just uh uh
is incoherent when you dig into it and
so I want to uh I want to get away from
it and what I want to do really is
rather than start with a definition is
just describe the phenomenon what what
do we want understand and that
phenomenon is that we spend our lives
apparently making decisions choosing
actions deciding what to do planning our
Behavior over long time frames and so on
so how could that be how could it be
that we ourselves our wh selves are in
charge of things and not just our brains
or not just our parts and for me as with
any complex phenomenon in biology I
think the best way to get a handle on
that is to take an evolutionary
perspective so if we can ground our
concepts of action and purpose and
meaning in in the simplest kind of
scenarios that should give us a better
way to understand the most complex
scenario that we know of which is the
human mind now when you do that though
there's a there's a third framing
problem which I think um really almost
scuppers things from the get-go which is
called determinism and that's the idea
especially predeterminism that the
lowlevel laws of physics just
predetermine everything that's going to
happen just because everything is made
of atoms and molecules and Quantum
fields and the way they interact is
completely determined by the laws of
physics and there's just one possible
future now if you accept that premise
then you end up doing one of two things
either you dismiss Free Will which to me
is dismissing the entire fundamental
phenomenology of our existence or you
end up tying yourselves in knots trying
to show that moral um responsibility can
be compatible with that kind of
determinism even when there's no
possibility of choosing there are no
possibilities at all in fact and that
challenge is much worse because it
doesn't just rule out free will in
humans it rules rules out any kind of
agency whatsoever in any kind of
organism how could we say that any
living being is doing something when
everything just unfolds in a
predetermined way now thankfully physics
doesn't say that physics doesn't say
that the universe is determined Min in
that way there's fundamental
indeterminacy at lots of levels the
quantum level but also classical levels
so what that means is that the future is
radically open what happens in the
universe is underdetermined by just
those low-level laws of physics and if
we start from that premise then we flip
the script we don't need to ask where
does freedom come from how could there
be Choice the freedom comes for free
it's just in the universe but now we
have to ask something else given all
this indeterminacy in the world and in
the noisiness of its own Parts how can
an organism control what
happens of all those possibilities how
can it make happen what it wants to
happen and fortunately that challenge
also presents the solution because the
fact that the future states of the
system both the organism and the world
are underdetermined by the low-level
details that opens the door for the way
the system is organized to have some
causal effect the organization can
constrain the possibility space and
there's nothing magic about that idea
it's utterly commonplace it's what lets
us design our artifacts so they can do
certain things and have certain
functions and that kind of functional
organization is exactly the defining
characteristic of living beings it's why
we call them organisms um at all in fact
and it becomes clear if we really think
about well what what is it what is a
living organism what does that mean to
be a to be a living self and really it's
a set of interlocking processes so even
at the simplest thing like a single cell
bacterium it's a set of of in this case
biochemical processes that collectively
maintain the dynamic pattern of the
whole thing and they create an
autonomous entity that persists through
time and it does that because it takes
in energy and it performs work to stay
out of equilibrium with the rest of the
environment so one way to do that that's
a challenge in in order to to stay
organized like that and persist through
time but one way to do that in a dynamic
environment is to be able to move around
because organisms need to take in energy
well they need to find
food so they need to know what's out in
the world and they need to be able to
move around and they need to have some
sort of internal Machinery that can
direct purposeful Behavior so even the
simplest organisms are doing that
they're approaching some good things
they're avoiding some bad things um and
and so the causation is not just
instantaneous physics they're doing
things for reasons already now when
things got more complicated when we had
multicellular life that has neurons and
muscles that that's a system to
coordinate all their bits so they can
move around in the world basically they
have to choose to do one thing at a time
out of some repertoire of actions and it
may be a simple repertoire or for us it
may be very very complex so they have to
take in information figure what figure
out what's out in the world
and then decide what to do about it
based on their own State their current
goals their current behaviors and so on
and so as as Evolution proceeded those
systems for control became more and more
complex more and more elaborate and more
and more internalized so for example if
we're doing Vision then we have to not
just sort of detect something we have to
infer what's causing it right what are
the causes of the pattern of photons
that are hitting my retina right now and
to do that we have to have some internal
representations so that's where
cognition really gets off the ground
because there's an internal space that
represents things that are out in the
world and our current states and goals
and so on and and beliefs and then uh
lets us figure out what to do and of
course nervous systems also give us the
ability to learn from experience so we
can learn about objects what are their
properties what are their causal
relations and contingencies what can be
done with them or by them what are our
what are our actions which ones turned
out well which ones didn't turn out well
all of that is used to guide our
Behavior to build these models of
ourselves uh and the world and predict
further into the future so when we're
thinking about organisms uh agency and
and the way they control their behavior
they're actively pursuing their own
agendas through time not just Moment by
moment they're flexibly accommodating to
changing circumstances or new
information but they're not just
reflexively acting acting to stimuli
they're directing and managing their
behavior for their own reasons so I
think that's a a a perfectly good
defense and naturalization of agency and
when you get to primates and you get to
humans that all gets much more
sophisticated much more internalized
where they're really doing cognition it
really is mental content that's driving
what happens not just the details of
neural firings and ultimately you get to
what we call metacognition the ability
of humans to not just have reasons but
to reason about those reasons we can
think about our own thoughts we can
represent the content of our own mind to
ourselves in a reflexive kind of a way
and we can deliberate about things
really not you know it's not doesn't
just seem that way we really do that so
what I would say is that like other
animals we have very complex Control
Systems we are complex selves that are
much more than just this conscious tip
of the iceberg and all of that is
guiding our behavior for reasons that
are our reasons not the reasons of our
parts and because we have those
capacities and this metacognitive
ability to reason about those reasons
and exert conscious cognitive control
then I'm happy to call that free
will thanks thank you very much um I'm
just going to ask each of you a question
first and then invite you to respond to
each other so um Susan first um that was
really interesting and um persuasive in
many ways but I've got a um a concern
with it that you seem to be inviting me
and others to choose to relinquish the
notion of Free Will which ends up being
a kind of um impossibility on your own
theory that you choose to relinquish the
idea of free will because you don't
choose because you don't have the
freedom to
choose yeah it's very it's weird and
paradoxical and I you know I wonder why
this person here has taken this route
well probably because the things I was
learning in my degree in Psychology and
Physiology or the fact I had this
boyfriend writing about weakness of the
will or the fact that I stumbled across
a brilliant zen teacher um a few years
later those things have carried through
and that's what's happened and there's a
consequence there are people like this
going around saying it's an illusion and
the the anyway the ideas in the air you
know it's been around a long time but
getting more so because of Neuroscience
so those are the things that have led
this person here this human being with
agency there's a whole human being with
agency but what there isn't is uh a
little me inside who Who's Who persists
and who makes the decisions that's how I
see
it uh Kevin I
wonder two things first of all I'm not
in a position to judge your claim that
physics is at a certain
level not um giving a determin universe
so that I mean if we accept that premise
which questions one of the premises that
are usually involved in setting up the
Free World debate it still doesn't seem
to follow that we have
agency because it depends how wide the
range of choices available are and how
just how we put ourselves in a position
to decide between them if we do decide
so that that was one topic but more
generally um would it be fair to say
that you're a compatibilist you are like
Daniel Dennis and David Hume somebody
who doesn't think there is a conflict
between the idea of the natural world as
described by science and the phenomenal
world as described by more or less every
human being in terms of their freedom of
choice that the two are not um at odds
with one another but are entirely
compatiable and Daniel danet talks about
um uh the kind of Freedom that we have
is the only free will worth wanting and
that's the Free Will of not being
manipulated by others uh Freedom comes
from choices made from within rather
than from without
crudely yeah I think um so for me um I
take Dan dennet to be saying that that
he's he takes moral responsibility to be
compatible with the idea of physical
predeterminism so he he accepts the
premise that there's only one future
possible physically and then he says
nevertheless we can treat organisms as
if they make choices because they're
complicated um and therefore we can
protect the idea of moral responsibility
and I that that idea just seems
incoherent to me because there are no
choices there are no possibilities
there's no reasons there's not even any
causes in a deterministic universe and
anyway physics doesn't say that that's
the way that things are so um so I would
say I'm absolutely a compatibilist when
it comes to thinking there's no magic
required for an organism as a
complicated system to be in charge of
itself I don't think that requires any
any magic what it does require is maybe
a change from thinking about causation
just in an instantaneous physical way to
thinking about causation in a historical
way and that for me is the really key
perspective shift that's required here
because the causation in a in a living
organism is not just instantaneous we
don't get a full explanation of what's
going on and why it happens
things happen we have our own reasons
because of things we've learned in the
past or because of evolution and our
development and directed towards things
in the future so for me the self only
makes sense not in an instant there's no
such the concept just doesn't apply in
an instant it only applies
longitudinally as temporally extended um
and so yeah I don't see any conflict
there with this idea of say top down
causation it's the kind of thing we see
all the time in like in computer
programs that's why we can have this
conversation over over the computer here
is because computer programs are written
in such a way that they cause physical
things to happen based on the intents
and desires of the people who program
them so um yeah I don't think we need to
to worry that there's any Supernatural
mysticism at play we can we can take a
very naturalistic uh approach to it I
hope but just to come back on that you
make a big distinction between organisms
which to varying degrees have control of
the kind that leads you to talk about
free
agency and mere matter as it were and
surely there's
something when language comes in that is
much more than just um responding to
stimula in that kind of immediate way
that the majority of animals do there's
something very special about that oh
yeah absolutely me I I I didn't talk
about it here but yes the sort of the
final stages in human evolution when we
get language and we get culture that
gives us a a kind of a of a first of all
it gives us a kind of a cognitive
Clarity because it it really really
precisely labels ideas and Concepts so
we can use them in more clear ways um
just individually but it gives us
Collective power right Collective
cognition and
communication um and I mean it shows
first of all that we really are
reasoning about our reasons because we
can tell each other about them and and
there's a huge adaptive advantage to be
able to do that when you think about
Collective action so yes I underplayed
it uh or I didn't mention it but
absolutely language and other aspects of
human cultural Evolution are hugely
important here in taking us Way Beyond
the agency that other animals have thank
you so Susan do you want to come back to
on I absolutely want to come back
absolutely um I I'm baffled I mean
you're you're you're basically telling a
story about Evolution very well that's
fine about how human human organisms
attain agency and how they attain more
agency and more kinds of agency but that
doesn't get at what most people think
about free will now in the beginning you
kind of almost completely rejected what
most people think about free will but
not completely I think what's happening
here is that it's important to make the
distinction between the physical
organism which is an amazing agent
that's evolved with more agency than any
other creature on the planet as far as
we know um and the way it feels that in
addition to this whole body there is
inside this me who makes the decisions
you talked about continuity and I think
that's really important the organism is
continuous oh yes we've shed cells and
things change and so on but there is a
continuity of this body from when it was
a baby to when it's going to die now is
there a continuity of a self well no um
the self is a construction that comes
and goes it disappears in sleep and Pops
back in lucier dreams sometimes um and
then starts up again in the morning it's
never exactly the same it's similar
because it's made by a similar brain um
again that's the Buddha's idea of no
self or non-self is there is no
persisting self and it it's an illusion
so you have I think you've done what Dan
denn's done I'm soorry keep keep talking
about him but I I can see why um which
is really to say you've talked about
human Freedom how these organisms have
acquired more abilities to do more
things and more clever ways of thinking
and talking and thinking about reasons
and so on but that doesn't mean that
there's free will in the sense that I'm
sure most people think about it that
it's the me inside who does
it yeah um I mean there's I think you
touch on something that that's really
interesting there first of all I'm going
to absolutely disagree with you on the
idea that our psychological selves don't
aren't real or don't persist um we have
our memories our habits our dispositions
our attitudes our policies our long-term
commitments um our Char our character
which really does persist absolutely
that's why we recognize each other as
being the same person through time of
course we don't persist in a static way
we persist by changing and and adapting
and so on but there's a through line
which absolutely is a real thing and I
think just because you can't localize it
in the brain somewhere which seems an
odd thing to want to do anyway doesn't
mean it's not it's not uh an entity or
or just because it's not an object so if
we think about it as a set of of you
know relational properties between all
the elements um that that make up our
psyche then yes there's a self and it
and it persists through time now is it
what people think it is um I don't know
I to me that's a separate question
really because um there's a sense of
self there's a sense of agency and Free
Will and and what those things feel like
to me is a different question from
whether there really is agency and
really is a self and really is Free Will
that we that we're engaging with it's an
important question but it's not the same
one and and but also I mean finally I I
would say I don't know what everyone
thinks about it I mean you said with
with some confidence that people think
there's a little me inside my head and
maybe that's right but maybe they also
think you know what uh maybe they
perfectly recognize I mean since the
time of Freud at least that there's lots
of subconscious going on that are still
part of my decision-making
processes and that while I you know I'm
doing habits and and ideas are popping
into my head and so on I'm not really uh
consciously in charge of those things I
could be right that I could introspect
about them I could I could examine those
and change my mind about them so um yeah
I'm not sure that people have that view
where it it's completely homuncular
little little me sitting inside there um
I think many people would be perfectly
happy to to recognize that theirselves
involve much more than that sort of just
that conscious bit well I'm going on
partly lots of lectures I've given lots
of asking people but also there have
been many surveys asking people what
they believe about about freeway
um and that the kind of thing that they
do tend to believe um that that
ultimately it it's me so the question
then from what you just said is is it
actually the construction and we do know
where in the brain it's going on we know
quite a lot about the construction of
Self in the brain and is it that that
makes these critical decisions that I
felt I freely made or not um I I think
not because it's involves all those
other things but I'd like to pick you up
on something
else this seems fundamental to your
argument you have taken the
indeterminacy of the universe which
really refers to there being random
events radioactive decay and all these
kinds of things and and subatomic sort
of things that all kinds of things can
um happen also I suppose Chaos Theory
things that happen because of you know
but this doesn't change the whole that
doesn't give people the ability to make
decisions uh to change the world you you
you seem to be implying but maybe you
can correct me if I've misunderstood
this that with all our clever brains and
the way we think we can change the world
to change these these random or chaotic
processes to go in One Direction rather
than another which would seem to me to
be paranormal or psychic I mean we can't
affect there have been lots of
experiments on whether because I used to
be a parapsychologist for my sins um on
whether people can influence random
number generators by the power of their
mind and they're not very convincing
evidence no no no I I must have got this
wrong but that I don't see how and and
nor does Dan denck because he's very
clear about that any determinacy would
give a loop
for that is indeed the tricky the tricky
bit so first of all let me just say if
the world were completely deterministic
there would be no there' be no agents to
talk of whether they're having agency or
not right it just would never have
evolved um in fact the universe would
never have evolved the way it is because
even to get galaxies you had to have
some Quantum fluctuations in the early
universe to get some inhomogeneties
right so that's an example of little
little Quantum fluctuations causing
massive things on on a massive G
Galactic scale okay
so so of course the rejoiner is well
indeterminacy doesn't get you free will
either if I'm just doing things because
of random events and that's not the idea
the idea is that it's underdetermined by
the laws of physics the way that the
system will evolve there are many many
possibilities what that allows is that
the way that the system is organized can
constrain that possibility space and as
I said that's utterly common place right
it's why we have uh designed systems
it's why we have policies and strategies
in businesses and organizations all
designed it's why we pay football
managers so much right because they
impose a strategy top down on their
players so there's nothing mysterious
about it uh and it wouldn't be possible
for that to have any causal effect if
all all the causes were down at the
bottom and they were and that were
causally complete so that's the idea is
that there's some causal slack in the
system as philos for George Ellis likes
to put it which allows the organization
of the system to do functional work and
causal causally effective work in by
constraining the possibility space and
that is exactly what living organisms do
that's how they stay alive by
constraining their bits to remain their
bits and not to fly off into the rest of
the universe can I all this is wonderful
for explaining how we get agency but you
know there no point in denying that we
have agency and that my cat has agency
of a much more limited extent that's
that's what you've done very
successfully talk about the evolution of
agency but that's not the same as the
evolution of Free Will which is this
this sense that it's not just down to
what this organism is doing there's also
a me who is controlling this organism
that seem to be left out of the story
can I can I um throw an example in here
and ask each of you what you would say
about it you mentioned football
something always intrigues me about
sports so
somebody's going for goal and there's an
Easy Pass they could make to a fellow
player they choose not to they go for
goal after the match the comment says
why didn't you make that pass and the
player tells a story now we think it was
a free choice that that person made they
could have they could have shot for goal
or they could have made the pass but in
that Split Second there's no interior
monologue going on there's not enough
time there's what what's going on there
so Susan what what would you say is
going on there we say it's a free choice
you know they they weren't forced to
shoot for
goal I would say it's a choice
definitely a choice um but it's not free
in the sense of if if you could really
look into all the situations um and find
out what was going on you would see that
this caused this and this caused the
other and the the memory of previous
similar examples or things that you
watched other people do or the feeling
the pain in your leg or any number of
things that would have contributed to
that decision did it and then after the
fact you know in life we can fabulate
all the time all I mean I work mostly on
Consciousness and there's so much stuff
on on how uh we attribute to this
magical thing called Consciousness all
sorts of um uh decisions and choices
when the mechanisms that are making them
happen so I I would be quite happy with
that applying to that football as to
everything else in
life Kevin what would you
say uh well a few things first of all I
think there are many instances where we
are not consciously deliberating on
things or consciously deciding on things
right and and that might be one example
where things are happening super fast
and we're just having to make
split-second decisions um and that's
fine I don't think that means that we
never consciously deliberate about
things so that's the first instance the
other is to think well what's actually
going on in that in that moment and I
think it you know as Susan said it draws
on all that past experience it draws on
all the learning the memory the
procedural skills that people have um
you know judging the possibility space
having a goal literally in this case
having a goal um and then figuring out
what's the optimal thing for me to do
right and so some of that most of that
happens
subconsciously that's fine that's good
right for most of our Behavior if we had
to think all the time consciously about
what we're doing and how we're going to
do it we'd be dead right I mean we have
to offload loads of that stuff to our
subconscious and so you know habits get
a bad RP we're always think about bad
habits most of our habits are good
they're adaptive that's why we have them
so um yeah so I would say there's all
kinds of stuff going on subconsciously
in that in that scenario and actually
for most of our Behavior it is caused by
prior things that have happened in the
sense that it's informed by them and
it's it's also formed by what we want to
happen in the
future and uh yeah all of that is
adaptive and on top of that we have
occasionally these these abilities to
engage conscious deliberation um which
you wouldn't want to do in the scenario
where you're you know running in on goal
what you do want to do when you're
thinking about more you know complicated
things and when you have the luxury of
time um to do that but would you call
that an example of free will or is it a
case
where it's not free will because you
didn't have time to refle I mean how
much how important is the notion of
conscious reflection to your concept of
free will I I I guess I'm less concerned
with saying this was an exercise of Free
Will and that wasn't and then with with
than with just saying we have the
capacity for free will in general and by
free will there what I mean is conscious
cognitive control so conscious consious
conscious control is the essence of Free
Will view that that for me is the extra
bit that I would say so I I would not
apply the term free will just because
it's really loaded right it's a really
loaded term I don't wouldn't apply that
to other creatures non-human creatures
so I think what makes humans different
from from the agency that other
creatures have is this extra reflective
capacity right and it could we could
call it metacognitive conscious control
if we want to I think that would maybe
would would do the trick um and again I
think there you know we need to
distinguish that capacity from the sense
of what that feels like which I think is
what I take Sue to be talking about Sue
would you like to come back on that yes
please uh this is great fun but um
because you're bringing in another magic
you're just bringing in Consciousness
there you're talking about the
subconscious and the unconscious in 100y
Old Freudian terms um which really don't
map on to what we know about now but
more critically the idea of I written it
down even conscious cognitive control
What on earth does that mean there's
this extra special thing called
Consciousness that comes in it it
doesn't make any kind of sense it's just
calling on something that we can't
measure we can't see we have all kinds
of problems with apart from what people
say they're conscious of um you've
spoken about Dand it so you must be
familiar with his um analysis of all the
traps that we fall into thinking that
Consciousness itself is something that
has power that can control things I
don't think that's true I can be wrong
about this because we are in such a
difficult state with trying to
understand Consciousness so I'm open to
you know completely having to change my
mind um but really I think it does not
make sense to call on this Consciousness
as though it were a power and does
things um or even to know what we are
conscious of or what we were conscious
of in the past and whether we did things
consciously these are all up for grab
it's really really tricky so I think
it's illegitimate to bring in conscious
cognitive control to help you out with
you know getting away from the fact that
Free Will is a losery now to the clock
ticking let him reply because I want to
knowon let reply but could you reply in
the context of giving a little summing
up of where you stand as well and then
I'll invite Susan to do the same and
then we'll have to sure sure so Su of
course is absolutely right that that
Consciousness is is incredibly
complicated we don't really understand
it very well uh but I think we can
describe things that are conscious
experiences or that aren't and we can
have instances where we have conscious
control or don't and there's lots of
neurological conditions for example
where people don't have conscious
cognitive control um of their behavior
so it doesn't have to be something
completely mysterious even though we
don't know how it it it is generated or
exactly everything about it we can at
least describe some phenomenology that
distinguishes um conscious from from
unconscious or subconscious or
non-conscious uh States or actions and
so on so um and and we're doing it now
right we're cons I'm consciously
deciding what I'm going to say I'm
consciously lifting my hand up and
putting it down and I and I know that
I'm conscious of my reasons for doing
those things because I can articulate
them right so we have this metacognition
that allows us to reason about our
reasons and and demonstrably do that
identify them and introspect about them
because we can articulate them to each
other and that has um as I said earlier
adaptive value so so overall what I
would say is that um I think we can
naturalize ideas of of Free Will um I
think we can naturalize them in the
context of the evolution of agency the
future really is radically open but
living organisms are designed to uh
determine what happens within that
possibility space for their own reasons
so they're really doing things unlike
everything else in the universe they
really have that causal power and humans
have it in Spades because we have these
extra layers o of um cognition and and
meta
cognition thank you very much now Susan
could you respond to that and sum up
your position and then we'll have to end
I'm
afraid well I think we need to have
another debate about Consciousness
because you have thrown in so many
contentious comments there um I would
say falling for the classic traps about
The Power Of Consciousness and the
evolution of Consciousness you said
Consciousness emerges from from the
brain or something like that which is
very contentious but let's forget that
for the moment um I have much enjoyed
having a go at this I think you have um
done a a great job of explaining or
talking about human agency and how it
has evolved and that is not to me what
free will is about it's something that
is sort of over and above it's more than
just the fact that this body can walk
around and eat and do the other things
it needs to do quite competently it's
something about this mythical me who who
has this control by some
incomprehensible means so I am going to
continue for now living my life without
Free Will and um I hope that we have
spread some ideas for people to think
about about their own free will hope so
so thanks very much for that both of you
to Susan Blackmore and Kevin Mitchell
and to intelligence squ for organizing
the debate and I should say Kevin
Mitchell's book free agents goes into
much more detail about the story that he
tells about how we got that particular
kind of agency thank you very much thank
you